what's the next category what's the next
category nickname
oh okay all right let's look at the
nominations
tough one monkey brain connor stephen
[Laughter]
is that a nickname really it's gonna be
now i guess
to your demise i am gonna quit this
podcast if that wins
uh and then we have wait did you boys
vote
huh did you give this vote i didn't vote
i didn't if i could
vote i would vote karen uh and then we
have grant for god that's not a nickname
that's his real name
and then the 93 for connor honestly i
want
at this point i want karen to win do you
like any of your nicknames
what do you think what do you think
this is the most garen picture he could
have checked where did we get this
picture from what is that
what is that picture this is when i did
uh i think it was on like
i did like a sushi video with chris on
like a different channel this is like
four years ago
and i'm wearing like the sushi hat on
the internet for this yeah jesus christ
steve jobs do you like that nickname i
[ __ ] love that [ __ ]
honestly yeah yeah because um yeah
because i'm the only one out of us three
that apparently wears turtlenecks
yeah that was the first time you said
full offer i look like a rapper steve
jobs personally um i've been battling
with the grand nickname from my entire
life so i've really
really i really hope to god that does
not win what do you think might win here
i have no idea i feel like because i
have two nicknames it could easily be
like the vote could be split right yeah
i mean so i i
would i wouldn't be surprised if uh
honestly like all i feel all of these
kind of
you know scratch a different itch for
the viewer
yeah i mean really i really don't know
but let's find out connor what's your
favorite nickname of the two
steve handjobs hell yeah hey grant
are you kidding me what about you
that wins um you're gonna get a new
saltiest moment
with the y actually what the [ __ ] is
that yeah it's m-o-n-k-e
come on come on come on that's pretty
monkey of you ashley i will say
the the one downside to having the 93
percent nickname is that whenever i
[ __ ] even interact publicly with a
girl everyone's like it's a 93 percent
it works
like no no no no no i'm just having a
conversation
please stop stop you're making it weird
please yeah the thing with about
93 is that that was something that
that's the longest lasting nickname
right
because that was mentioned in episode
one episode one for this day
and it's just i think it's just stuck i
don't mind i just i just sometimes i
worry about the other person
when they like right i'm talking
i'm literally talking to a woman please
stop who knew you could have a platonic
relationship
online and the trash taste of wardu for
best nickname
[Music]
is
i'm so happy about that you know what
i'm i'll [ __ ] take it i love that
nickname
oh things i named never win can we get
the
the breakdown of the post how do you
guys get a breakdown steve
jobs won with 32.3 percent thirty two
pounds it's pretty comfortable yeah
second place was connor's monkey brain
of course
yeah and that place was the ninety three
percent with nineteen points
yeah yeah yeah i think the vote got
split yeah they all scratched different
itches right
yeah yeah yeah i think when you have two
ones that contend really well
i think that vote might be split because
i think steve hand jobs is just better
than grant
yeah i think it's easier to vote for i
think sorry no bias there i think it's
better
it's it's definitely better i'm so
[ __ ] glad
came like last right did he come last uh
grant no grant was fourth
karen came last are you happy joey are
you happy i love you guys